our next speaker
has been doing Brazilian Jiu Jitsu for
13 years
everyone please welcome ayanti hi
everyone uh my name is ayanthi I'm
currently a data analyst at 1-800
Flowers but today I'm going to talk
about how to create accurate and
beautiful maps in r
so just a quick overview of what we're
going to talk about today we'll talk
about me we'll talk about geospatial
data overall how to use it in R and some
resource some geospatial resources for
you guys
so what do I a data analyst at 1-800
Flowers have to say about geospatial
data so for eight years I worked at the
intersection pun intended at
transportation and data at two different
New York City agencies I'm taking a
break from City Planning as a career but
I'm still really interested in
geospatial data in maps I mapped all the
TLC vehicle trips in the city I worked
with car crash data so I'm very familiar
with geospatial data also my interest in
maps comes from the fact that my family
is from a place that is frequently left
off Maps my family is from Sri Lanka
that little island South of India
and there's even a subreddit called maps
without Sri Lanka
um all small plug I'm on the board of
New York City chapter of our ladies I'm
highly encouraged all women and gender
minorities to join our Meetup feel free
to talk talk with me about that after
this
um so geography is one of the oldest
Sciences
a map is probably the First Data
visualization you ever saw or interacted
with there in childhood puzzles they're
in probably every classroom in America
there's one in your pocket if you have
Google Maps
um there are in tons of TV shows Dora
the Explorer anyone
um
so to this point geospatial is one of
the oldest forms of science you know
finding the curve of the Earth maps of
the Age of Exploration and in the modern
world it's becoming even more popular
you know citing for land uses you know
deciding where to put schools Farms
retails Etc space exploration military
operations population patterns using
Census Data dystopian surveillance
everything GIS data is used for
everything
um so some terms that are commonly
tossed around but unless you studied GIS
you might not be familiar with so GIS
just stands for geographic information
system so that is an all-in-one
framework for Gathering managing and
analyzed data for the longest time this
was done with traditional and frankly
clunky GIS software with a very
expensive license
and the good thing it was all in one
point and click but the good thing about
R is that it's free so you can do all of
this work much more quickly and for free
cartography is just the science or
practice of drawing maps
and you may have heard the word
shapefile
um so that is where Geographic data has
been traditionally stored on Vector data
specifically we'll talk about what
Vector data is later and Vector data
largely represents some points lines and
polygons and it contains the location
information and all the attributes of
that geospatial point line or polygon
and as GIS becomes more open source
other formats are becoming more popular
you may have heard of geopackage geojson
kmls
um and even like you can take a CSV with
lat long and Pull It in R and manipulate
it so that you can project it onto a map
now Vector data versus raster data
unless you're in environmental science
you'll probably be mainly working with
Vector data which points lines and
polygons and each type needs to be
stored separately so points and lines
cannot be in the same file
raster data I don't want to get too in
depth but it's basically a digital image
where each pixel represents a value so
the two examples up here are of
elevation and land cover you take these
images from high up and each pixel is
given a value based on the elevation or
the land use
and when you're creating a map there's a
lot of different layers that need to
come together to make your map and
different types of data are represented
in different layers and each layer is
going to have two attributes the spatial
and the non-spatial attributes so
spatialism the latitude and longitude
the location information and then the
non-spatial information you know so if
you have a census tract you'll have the
lat long for that but then you'll also
have you know maybe the population
number of people under 18 things like
that
and this is a very important concept
that a lot of data scientists don't
really know because again if you didn't
have like a city planning or geography
academic background it's not really top
but it's really important
so a map is a visual representation of
reality and it's just always going to be
distorted because at the end of the day
you're taking a small slice of the globe
and flattening it to create a map so the
way I like to explain this is that think
about peeling an orange
and how different that piece of the peel
looks when you flatten it out depending
on where you started and the peel the
size of the peel you can peel it in a
million different ways
and the geographic coordinate system
describes what the location is on Earth
relative to the equator the prime
meridian so since the Earth is round
sorry flat earthers um this is measured
in angular units usually degrees
and projected coordinate system is a
geographic coordinate reference system
that has been flattened so when using a
projected coordinate system that
flattened part of the earth you can
measure distances using a straight line
and I'm not going to go too much into
the text here but I'm just going to show
you some of the different ways the globe
slash orange can be sliced so you see
where the iconic projection it's because
you're taking that like
area where the cone touches the Earth
and you're flattening it out
and since the cone is wider than it's
tall the map will become more distorted
As you move north or south of the
standard parallel
cylindrical projection this is used
often for world maps imagine just taking
like a strip around the center and
taking that portion of the Earth
planar projection this is the most
common issues day of doing say like a
map of New York or a very small specific
area imagine just taking like a piece of
paper tangent to the globe and where it
touches the globe that's the part of the
earth you're taking
so some best practices in visualizing
geospatial data first of all who is your
audience I think a lot of New Yorkers
especially assume that everyone has the
knowledge of New York that they do some
people might not know what you mean when
they say the five boroughs so how to
best explain and describe things
um
always normalize your data
because of things like unequal
Geographic boundaries areas and
populations it can make the data scene
concentrated when it's really just a
representation of population density
um one thing I see in a lot of maps is
over labeling keep labels to a minimum
over labeling makes it hard to read and
overwhelming I've seen a bunch of maps
where every street is labeled and that's
just too much it's overwhelming for the
reader
and think critically about your color
palette
um so does your organization have its
own color palette accounting for color
blindness or other visual disabilities
and uh industry standard so when I was
working in City Planning you have the
lbcs color codes for different land uses
so residential is always yellow
industrial is gray things like that
and then document all changes to the
source data one thing I like about
working with geospatial data in R is
that you can pull in the shapefile into
your working environment on R and
manipulate it and keep it in your
working
keep it in the IDE without
um
editing the original file but make sure
you document all the changes you may be
joining shapefiles to census data so
keep in mind how you document all your
stages
so I pulled this example of a map
because I think it's extremely well done
and it really showcases all the really
important visual map elements this is
from the New Jersey bike ped
organization and this is a map of Jersey
City's land use in 2012.
so it has all the Essential Elements
which are the map itself
um very clear Legend uh title and data
sources please always put your data
sources especially for things like the
census where these tables change over
time it's really important to have the
source and when you pulled it
some optional things they're more common
in traditional Maps like this but you
have your North Arrow scale bar and
labels in my experience scale bars are
especially important for smaller Maps
because you don't always have the best
idea of distance
um
yeah where the RL scale of our labels
so now we have all this data we have all
this information so what do we do with
it
we can use any combination of this data
to make a good map using too much data
or the wrong type of data will ruin a
map
and the following slides contain
examples of bad or misleading Maps or
cartography practices
so this nightmare huge headache please
don't make a map like this
um like every state has a different logo
that fills up the entire State the
entire East Coast like everything's in
the Atlantic Ocean this is just a lot
please don't do this it's good for a
buzzfeed article I guess but nothing
else
um and just a reminder that sometimes
you don't you haven't really found a
geospatial pattern is just a population
map
um a bunch of my GIS friends sent me
this cartoon and I just like I think I
have to put in this presentation because
it's so true
um misleading election Maps I see these
every year
um this is always like a quote-unquote
own the libs Maps because of all the red
um but in reality like a lot of these
areas are not densely populated so it
makes you think like oh everyone wrote
it red we should have a Republican
president but no it's just
it's just like a population density map
and to the New York Times point I have
the source at the bottom they say this
is a misleading map
um this is just bad blue is there twice
in the legend it's like the colors are
months and no stay-at-home orders every
single state is labeled I got like a
huge headache when I saw this map please
don't ever do this
and I'm gonna bring up my personal beef
with zip codes
um so zip codes are a terrible
Geographic battery to use and I broke
one of my rules in over labeling but I
had to do it here
so this is a close-up of Midtown and
downtown Manhattan soilu you'll notice
there's a ton of zip codes in this like
area of just a couple neighborhoods and
for example the empire state has its own
ZIP code so you shouldn't really be
using these boundaries because frankly
they're not based on anything except for
mail routes it's better to use things
like census tracts or block groups
neighborhood boundaries things like that
but please don't use zip codes if you
can help it
so I'm going to just talk a little bit
about some of our packages used to make
maps uh
packages for manipulating especially
this is an incomplete list the ones on
the left are the ones I use the most the
ones on the right I've used a little bit
but aren't as familiar with I would say
the main one to use is SF that's the one
you use to bring in this data and
manipulate it
um
doing spatial joints and various spatial
functions ggplot2 is great for static
Maps
leaflet is the best for dynamic
visualizations that I found
um but yeah feel free to look into all
of these there's a ton of documentation
on all of them especially SF
so I'm going to show you now some maps
that have been made in r
not to flex but I made these Maps
um and I think this is um I put them up
here today because I think this is a
good example of how you can use the same
data to get two different answers so if
you look on the one on the left with the
gradient it looks like wow the East
Village opened a million restaurants in
March 2022.
um but if you look on the right or I've
bucketed into quintiles you'll see oh
like it's really just the East Village
probably had an outlier but in the top
bucket you have a lot of Manhattan North
Brooklyn and Western Queens so I think
this is a better way on the right
personally to visualize the data I'm
sure there are better ways but I thought
this was a good example of
showing the data in two different ways
can give you two different answers
this this is using openstreetmap data
this guy Milos Popovich and he makes
these incredibly stunning maps in our
his website is there highly suggest you
check it out for not only his
visualizations but he has some good
tutorials on there
this like my jaw drop when I saw this I
didn't know you could make relief Maps
like this in R but this is using the
ratiator package I found it on Twitter
the title is beautiful he does the
source at the bottom the package he used
and it's just like I really didn't think
you could make this in R until I saw it
these are two gifs I made
um these represent a day's worth of New
Jersey Transit and New York City subway
trips so public transit agencies
released this data called gtfs Data so
it gives you the public transit schedule
so this assuming the trains run on time
LOL this is
um the movement of trains throughout the
day
so it's a time lapse and you can see it
slows down after rush hour and picks up
during the morning
and um these are the resources that I
found most useful how to lie with maps I
think especially if you're like a data
scientist transitioning to work with
geospatial stuff it's a fantastic
introduction
geocomputation in R it's free online
those three authors regularly contribute
to the r geospatial ecosystem and
they're pretty active on Twitter too if
you have questions which is cool
and then I just have a list there of
geospace professionals with educational
content they post a lot on Twitter for
those who still use it and even on
LinkedIn they will post visualizations
and instructionals so super useful
and then I'm always going to shout out
to New York City open data portal
um there's a ton of geospatial data sets
to get you started with analysis I used
to clean some of that data before it
went on the open data portal so you're
welcome
and um thank you everyone for listening
um that's a very famous map but I don't
know the projection of hogsmead so sorry
about that
um and I have my GitHub at the bottom
feel free to talk with me about
geospatial stuff after this is over I
love talking about GIS please anything
GIS R ladies related I'm here
um
so thank you everyone for listening to
me today and I hope you got a little
something out of this
[Applause]